THIS BED.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: TEXAS HOLD ITS
PRIMARY ELECTIONS LAST NIGHT.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS ARE NOW A MERE EIGHT
MONTHS FROM NOW.
DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING MAKE GAINS
EVERYWHERE, BUT LONG-TERM, STATE
OF TEXAS IS THEIR TOP PRIORITY,
IT'S EASY TO SEE WHY.
TEXAS IS A HUGE STATE.
THE BIGGEST ESTATE THAT BOASTS
REPUBLICAN.
IF TEXAS GOES BLUE, DEMOCRAT,
IT'S OVER.
REPUBLICANS CANNOT WIN A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION WITHOUT
TEXAS.
AMERICA WOULD THEN BE ONE PARTY
STATE FOR A GENERATION AT LEAST,
MAYBE LONGER.
GIVEN THE TOLERANCE FOR ANYTHING
THAT RESEMBLES REPUBLICAN
DISSENT.
WITH THE STAKES SO HIGH, WHAT
WOULDN'T DEMOCRATS DO TO WIN?
WHY WOULDN'T THEY ENCOURAGE
NONCITIZENS TO VOTE?
OF COURSE, THEY'RE ALREADY DOING
THAT EXPLICITLY IN OTHER STATES.
AND TEXAS, IT WOULD MAKE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE.
TEXAS HAS THE SECOND-HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF NONCITIZENS AND
AMERICA AFTER CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE MORE THAN 3 MILLION
NONCITIZENS IN THE STATE
OVERALL.
FOR PERSPECTIVE, HILLARY CLINTON
LOST TEXAS BY ONLY 800,000
VOTES.
YOU DO THE MATH.
THE TEMPTATION IS THERE, IT'S
OVERWHELMING.
WHAT ACTUALLY STOPS NONCITIZENS
FROM VOTING IN TEXAS?
GOOD QUESTION.
NOT MUCH.
JUST RATION IN THAT STATE IS
CONDUCTED ON THE HONOR SYSTEM AS
IT IS IN MANY STATES.
THE ONLY WAY YOU WERE OUT IT A
NONCITIZEN VOTER IN TEXAS IS
WHEN YOU DECIDE TO ADMIT THAT
YOU ARE.
TEXAS JUST ASSUMES THAT ALL
VOTERS ARE TELLING THE TRUTH.
IMAGINE IF JEWELRY STORES HAVE
THE SAME POLICY.
THEY ASSUMED NOBODY WOULD EVER
CONSIDER STEALING A NECKLACE.
THAT'S CRAZY.
ELECTIONS ARE MORE IMPORTANT
THAN NECKLACES, BUT FOR SOME
REASON, WE DON'T ACT THAT WAY
AND MOST STATES.
ACCORDING TO THAT TEXAS ATTORNEY
GENERAL KEN PAXTON, THERE IS
ALREADY AMPLE EVIDENCE OF VOTING
IN TEXAS.
THEY INVESTIGATED 254 COUNTIES
AND 165 UNLAWFULLY REGISTERED
VOTERS.
IT MAKES YOU WONDER, WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE STATES OTHER
250 OF COUNTIES QUESTION WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW, WE CAN GUESS.
THE LEFT PRETENSE, THAT'S NOT
REAL, IT'S NOT EVEN POSSIBLE.
THEY'RE LYING.
VOTER FRAUD BENEFITS THEM.
THIS IS WHAT FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE
AN ELECTION.
DEMOCRATS ARE OPENLY PUSHING IT
WHEN THEY AREN'T MAKING IT
EASIER FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO
REGISTER TO VOTE, THEIR FIGHTING
EFFORTS TO IDENTIFY FRAUDULENT
VOTERS.
IT WOULD MAKE THE WHOLE SCHEME
LEGAL IF IT PASSED.
REPUBLICAN'S ARE HELPING WITH
THAT FOR SOME REASON.
LET THEM INPUT AND WAS NEVER
THAT AMBITIOUS, BY THE WAY.
CHRISTIAN ADAMS IS PRESIDENT --
HE JOINS US.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
WHEN YOU HEAR PEOPLE SAY THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN, THERE ARE SO
MANY QUESTIONS.
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPEN.
THE REAL QUESTION IS WHY AREN'T
STATES, WHY ISN'T TEXAS
SPECIFICALLY NOT DOING ANYTHING?
>> THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS.
SOMETIMES THE LEFT GETS INVOLVED
IN LITIGATION, THEY TRY TO STOP
US FROM DOING ANYTHING.
IN KANSAS RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE
KANSAS TRIED TO DO SOMETHING,
AND THE ACLU AND A WHOLE BUNCH
OF INTERNATIONAL LAW FIRMS,
DECKARD, --
AMERICANS SHOULD BE ELECTING
AMERICAN OFFICIALS, NOT
FOREIGNERS.
IN TEXAS, WE ASK FOR THE
VULNERABLE CANCELLATIONS OF
NONCITIZENS.
IN HARRIS COUNTY, WHICH IS
HOUSTON AND SAN ANTONIO.
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO THAT
INFORMATION UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
THOSE TWO COUNTIES ARE
STONEWALLING US AND NOT LETTING
US SEE THE DATA.
>> Tucker: WEARS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IN TEXAS IN THIS?
>> HE'S DOING GREAT.
THE PROBLEM IS WORSE THAN YOU
JUST INTRO.
IT'S MUCH WORSE.
THEY'RE FINDING IN TEXAS,
NONCITIZENS ACROSS THE STATE AND
THEY'RE DOING IT IN A WAY THAT
VERY FEW STATES ARE DOING.
MOST STATES HAVE THE HONOR
SYSTEM.
YOU CHECK A BOX, YOU SAY YOU'RE
A CITIZEN, YOUR ON THE ROLE,
PERIOD.
>> Tucker: WE SPENT THE LAST
TWO YEARS EMBROILED IN A SCANDAL
THAT'S BASICALLY STOPPED NORMAL
WORK IN WASHINGTON AND IT
SURROUNDS THE IDEA OF FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE IN AMERICAN
ELECTIONS.
HERE YOU HAVE ACTUAL DOCUMENTED
EVIDENCE, THEIR VOTING, THE MOST
SACRED THING CITIZENS DO IN THE
LEFT SAYS WE WANT MORE THAN
LEFT SAYS WE WANT MORE THAN    O
LEFT SAYS WE WANT MORE THAN    F
LEFT SAYS WE WANT MORE THAN    T
LEFT SAYS WE WANT MORE THAN    A
LEFT SAYS WE WANT MORE THAN    .
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> THEY LIKE IT.
THEY ENJOY HOW FOREIGNERS ARE
VOTING.
THEY HIDE THE BALL, THEY LIE,
THEY DON'T TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT
THE EXTENT OF THE PROBLEM.
THEY TRY TO PREVENT US FROM
FINDING OUT HOW BAD THE PROBLEM
REALLY IS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S SO CYNICAL,
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
HAPPENING, BUT IT IS.
MY QUESTION, ILLINOIS IS A
DEMOCRATIC STATE.
TEXAS HAS A REAL REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR.
FOR NOW COME OUT, THAT WILL